at the end of it Herbert about
God of all the way back into
this thing. How did you see
Derek Carr and that Raiders
team, figure out a way to get
into the playoffs here.
Well, I thought it was a great
team effort. I thought Max
Crosby and the fourth quarter.
He completely took over
the game from a defensive
standpoint, the level of
pressure and I was really
surprised that the Chargers did
not have any help for their,
right? Tackle. Nobody's
chipping. Nobody's
double-teaming. Nobody's giving
Max Crosby enough attention,
man. He completely took over
the game on the defensive side
of the ball, on our offensive
side of the ball. Josh. Jacobs
wasn't 100%. We knew that. But
then when he came in the game he
was
And late in that fourth quarter.
He broke a couple big runs
and really just impose that
physical
that, physical, just that
physical running style against
that defense.
And, you know, there's always,
you have a weird feeling about
their car right there car. I
don't know that he gets enough
credit off the field. What he's
been able to do to keep this
locker room. Keep this building,
keep this team
together to make it to this
point in the season. I thought
we really heard that after the
game were talking to Josh
Jacobs in the way that Josh
Jacobs talked about his
relationship with Derek Carr. I
want to run this clip one time
hear this.
Josh, I want to ask you about
Derek Carr, cause I was
watching him warm up. You could
just tell there was something
different about this game. What
it meant to him, what it meant
to his career. How is pairing
with car impacted your career,
man? I
told him, I said man
coming into this game. I said
it's going to come down to me.
You
said we don't have one of us
will have to make plays
and I told him, I said, man,
you owe yourself this. I'll see
the work that he put in every
day when he doing. He don't want
to talk me how to read
things are. As offensive likes
quarterback.
I'm not there. I make protection
calls and things like that.
He told me that and I mean, this
is a big Testament to who
he is mean he's a great guy on
and off the field.
And Jack
Jack. The fact that Josh Jacobs
will come out and say something
like that. It just shows you the
level of respect that he
has because Josh Jacobs, he's a
football guy. And, you know,
I told you this
on Sunday. I said nobody's gone
through more adversity.
I mean, who's been stronger than
their car to go to lose
your coach lose some players and
just keep that team focus.
And, you know, when you going
through situations like that,
everyone puts the focus and
attention on the
quarterback, and the fact that
Josh. Jacob said he learned,
Pass protection and things like
that from Derek are those are
the type of things that leaders
do.
That's not always at the
Forefront of everybody's, you
know, everybody's information.
So, Props to Derrick Harmon.
I'm out.
And that's why I say we talk
about MVP who's truly more
valuable to their team. Was it
Derek Carr or wasn't Aaron
Rodgers and I think Derek Carr
deserves to be in that
conversation. We know Aaron
Rodgers going to eventually win
at Tom Brady should be
second. But Derek Carr should at
least be in that top three
or top four. Because what he's
been able to Going this year to
responsibility and just
everything. The way he's
continued to play
and and allow this team to
ascend. It's just been
fantastic.
I hear you, man. It's been
amazing to watch it. And
I really like to hear Josh
Jacob, say that he and car got
together. Individual and said,
if we're going to win this
game, if we're going to take
this group to the playoffs.
It's going to be on us.
It's going to be all one is
going to be onto me and you,
man.
And that's what it came down to.
Even when you get to
overtime of that game in the
Chargers go down. They get
a field goal and out of Raiders,
were coming back down
the field. It was Josh Jacobs,
just refusing to go down and
fighting for extra yards
and eventually breaking that
first down. Run
that got it over the top and
that's what this team goes
through.
I'm not a big proponent of first
round running backs, or
spending those kind of resources
in the running back
position. But Josh Jacobs is the
kind of player that's worth
that. He's the heartbeat of that
team. He catches the ball
out of the backfield. He breaks
all these tackles. I mean, he's
the reason this is a
playoff team right now. He
refused to go down one of
the best games of his whole
career. And one of the biggest
moments.
Absolutely, and I'm gonna tell
you something, this offensive
line has taken a lot of
criticism throughout the year.
And I thought they did a really
good job. I mean, this is not
the best offensive line.
Obviously
there has some positions where
they got some young guys,
but I thought this out offensive
line, really stood up
and did an excellent job. The
one question. I want to ask you
or talk to you about is Brandon
Staley and I think he has to do
a better job of managing his
game managing his team.
We talked about the aggressive
style. He's trying to come in
and change the mindset and build
confidence in that team.
And we
That. But at the same time,
Jack, I mean, how do you go for
it on your own 18-yard line? I
mean, is that is that
arrogance? Is that Cockiness?
What
is that? Or is that flat-out
stupidity?
You can't put your team in a
situation like that
when they're fighting their
butts off every single play and
then you put them at a
disadvantage going forward on
an 18-yard line.
I think there's a there's a
healthy level of
aggressiveness, which he showed.
And then there's
an unhealthy level of
aggressiveness, which he showed
in the biggest game of the year.
For him at that. I just
pushed it too far. Showed a
little bit of his inexperience
really in a lot of ways and it's
probably the most
egregious go for it moment that
I've seen since you all the way
going back to the Bill Belichick
one and we talked
about this in the car ride home
after the game and I'll even
let you tell that story. But
when Bill Belichick went for
out about his own 20-yard line
this,
this remind me of that moment.
And I think that the Chargers
probably would have won this
game. Surely would have been in
a way better position to go win
this game. This is early third
quarter at your own 18 yard
line,
you're showing that you can stop
this team. It wasn't like
Derek. Carr was flying up and
down the field. It was
the 50-yard, Chris Harris, jr.
Pass interference. The put the
ball
at the one-yard line, and then
you had the muffed punt,
the fumbled punt that also set
up the other Raiders touchdown.
So
I don't think you needed
to just give up on your defense
punt. The ball go try to win
the game and instead he just
goes for Full Hail Mary with
the fourth and one in his own
18, and it totally backfires
and sets up the Raiders
perfectly.
Yeah, when I look at the charges
defensively they
definitely have some needs on
the defensive side of the ball.
If they really want to take it
to the next level. I think
they're pass rushers are good.
We talked about who China new.
Oh, so that's your guy.
He was all over the field. We
know about Bosa,
but to me what they need is,
they need a big 320 pounds. Big
physical defensive tackle.
That's going to be a run
plugger dance. Can they can hold
two or three people up.
That's what they need. I look at
linebacker Kenneth Murray.
I mean, he was a first-round
draft choice, and he's
On the field. When he's on the
field, they're making big
plays. He gets off the field and
it's like, okay. Where is
this first round? Pick at like,
he's a first round pick. He's
Kenneth Murray's healthy.
He should be out there on the
field and they haven't gotten
a lot of production from him.
And in the last point, I want to
make is Austin Eckler. We love
Austin Eckler, and he's their
best and most productive player.
Like in those critical moment.
You have to give him the
football
and it was like, okay. Where's
Austin? Actually, I know Justin
Herbert, he's tough. He's got a
big strong arm, but in some of
those critical moments, it's get
it because he's such
a mismatch and he's so difficult
to tackle in the open field.
I didn't think
they'd the offensive
coordinator. Did a great job of
getting him involved in the game
late.
I think that's a great point. I
tell you what else, that I was
a little thrown off about
watching the charges. And will
you pick them? A big reason why
I was Keenan Allen, Mike
Williams.
Those were two of their best
players on their whole team
specifically on their offense,
for sure. It took until late
fourth quarter over time for
those guys to get going.
I mean, just the Herbert. You
got to trust him a little bit.
Let
him go
sling that thing. I thought they
were a little conservative
early in that game. We really
was awesome, Jared Cook
catches, but you got to get your
best players. The ball in
to go that long and the game.
Without getting Mike Evans and
Keenan. Allen significant
touches is almost a guaranteed
losing formula.
Absolutely, and we even talked
about Jared Cook. You were
screaming at the TV throat
abatage are cookies wide open.
He's 67. He made some couple a
couple catches early. They're
really kept the momentum going
but
you know, it's just the
offensive coordinator making
Mike Williams. Making Keenan
Allen priorities. Everything
doesn't have to be a five to
seven drop back where you're
throwing a ball down the field
and you know integrate some of
that quick pass in gaming in
there too. To get those guys
involved.
Yeah, I mean you saw what I was
capable of at the end. It was
like three fourth and tens on
that final drive that they
converted. I Herbert. Let's one
go it whistles out of his hand.
The one guy I want to give
credit to before we get out of
here
is Rich besides Chia, right? The
head coach who comes in and
nobody even talks about his
under the radar, but you could
just tell that he is a rock. He
is just a Cornerstone Rock for
that program and
Josh Jacobs was telling us after
the game. He's like when
bad things happen in your life.
He's the first person you want
to talk to when
Things happen in your life.
He's the first person that you
want to talk to you.
I thought that spoke volumes
about who he is
and you know, what his calm
demeanor. You read some of
the Articles they say his calm
demeanor or not having someone
yelling and screaming every time
you make a mistake afraid
to come to the sidelines in
Gruden
as opposed to a guy like this
coach is going to bring you
inside, talk to you and really
stay patient and understanding
those guys. I'm telling I talked
to more than just one
Raider. They said they love this
guy, they don't care about
big.
Um guys, coming in here. He
understands the tone of
the locker room. He understands,
you know, just everybody and
I think he should get another
opportunity. Even if you sign
this guy to a one-year deal,
give him a one-year deal.
Pay him some real, some real
coaches money. All right? Pam,
567 million bucks allowed, give
him an opportunity to win this
locker room. If you're not 100%
convinced, if you are 100%
convinced,
then sign him to a long-term
deal.
So now you don't have to worry
about, finding your next
culture getting caught up in
that coaching carousel.
I think he's earned the right
man. You're not going to find
a harder circumstance in the one
that he walked into this year.
Give him an opportunity to get
to the second one, which is
the Indianapolis Colts. The
Colts have had one of the
ultimate
roller coaster seasons
and it ended with just a crash
and burn,
two losses down the stretch. How
did the Colts let this
entire year? In the momentum.
They had built altars run away
from them.
Do we talked about this? And
I've told you all year, I said,
I'm not a big fan of this Carson
Wentz, Carson Wentz was
in a perfect situation. He came
to the perfect situation,
a coach that loved him.
All right? A coach that wanted
him,
a great offensive line. You got
the leading rusher in NFL as
your running back. Okay, and you
got some big receivers and
Pittman Jr.
T Y, Hilton. Like the offense
was tailor-made for you. And
the last game of the season
against one of the worst teams
in the National Football. Ball
league, they beat you. So I'm
not a big, but I've never been a
big believer of Carson Wentz.
I've never thought old coderre
Carson Wentz away from
getting to a championship. I
think he's the guy that's
ultimately holding them back. We
saw him out in San
Francisco, drop back. Throw a
ball up to three or four times,
you know, and they come down
with the ball or it's a pass
interference things like that
happen, but can you stand in
a pocket in those key moments
and make those big throws? And
he's
not able to do it against the
Jacksonville Jaguars?
And for me
the coat It's not getting into
the playoffs.
If I didn't like Frank Reich,
the way I like him. That's
a fireable offense because it's
just way too much talent on
this team not to be in a playoff
sitting at home.
Watching everybody else this
weekend.
It's tough. When your
quarterback is bad in three of
the last four games in the money
time, and that's when he
struggled the most right? It was
New England was horrible in
that game Vegas. Gave that game
away and then comes back in
the final game of the year
against Jacksonville. And
all you got to do is just go
beat Jacksonville to win team
and he's horrible against of
three of the last four to be at
your worst is a bad situation.
Let's hear it from Carson Wentz
after this game after this
season there. Now, packing up
and going home, here was the
quarterback of the Cults.
It's a bad feeling
completely bad feeling
knowing that
you know, we were in control
being in control of our
destiny,
last two weeks and we just
couldn't get it done and it's
definitely got left a bad taste
in my mouth. A lot of guys
mouth
not where we want to be. Not,
you know what we expected
either,
you know, we expected to finish
stronger than we did and we
didn't get it done. It's a bad,
bad bad feeling.
We kept saying we we we but I'm
just looking at him. I'm
waiting for him to say I'm the
coach. I am the quarterback of
this team. That's on me. I have
to play better. Forget about.
We need to play better as a team
if I'm if I'm the quarterback
and I know I stunk it up and
it's for the world to see.
I'm coming out and say, you
know, I have to do better as
a quarterback. I was brought in
here to win these games. Okay,
you not brought in here to lose
these games. They're paying you
25, 30 million a year to win
these football games. And
to me I'm just not a big
believer in Frank, Wright, and
Chris Ballard, the general
manager. They, I think they
really blew it on this
situation,
and they're going to have to
re-evaluate after this next
year and just see what happens.
But I'm not a believer in
Carson Wentz will see what
happens in the future.
Because there was a really slow
start to the year, they lost
four out of their first five.
That's what happened to them.
And then they got hot that
ground game. Jonathan Taylor
shoot. He was an MVP candidate.
The offensive line Clinton
Nelson, came back, healthy.
Quit Nelson, never really
completely looked like Quentin
Nelson to me, even when he was
out there playing you had that
ankles. So taped up. It was
almost like he's wearing a cast
on that thing and I've I've seen
him be so explosive back
to his days at Notre Dame is
time with the Colts
where he just looks like the
best athlete and the trenches,
you know, anywhere
and he never Really looked like
that. He kind of looked like he
was playing with one leg at 50%.
The other leg at 100% And
just hobbling his way around.
And I don't think we ever saw
him Dominate and that offensive
line needs him to be
a dominator there. So let's hear
from the head coach and
Frank Reich after this season,
just got away from him.
I know it's the day after the
season, but as you sit, there
right now, do you expect Carson
Wentz to be your quarterback in
2022? As far as Carson? Again,
I mentioned this the other day,
just with individuals.
We love the team. We had this
year. We knew everyone, we
brought in this year.
We expected to play winning
football.
Next. Year's roster will be next
year's roster.
I'm not going to evaluate or
talk about any. I don't want to
just open it up with one player
and then start talking about
all of them. So
Hey, that's his guy.
You know, he's going to protect
this guy and you know, Carson
Wentz you talk about his
confidence being very fragile
at this point. I'm so Frank
right? He's doing the right
thing. He's protecting his
quarterback, but at the end of
the day, some of those
behind-the-scene conversations,
man, you sit back and wonder
what they're actually talking
about.
I know if I'm a player in that
locker room. I would be
frustrated. You have a defense
that could create turnovers one
of the best defenses in the NFL.
You got the offense, like
I described it. And you have
Carson Wentz. And I just
There's no way you're going to
get to a Super Bowl, get to
that next level with him playing
quarterback.
Well, she with the end up doing,
I'll tell you what,
don't sleep on the Jags. Either.
Do not sleep on those
Jacksonville Jaguars because
they were playing some inspired
football in this game, and it
with the rookie quarterback.
They've just been trending
slowly upward. I think Trevor
Lawrence gonna be fine in this
league.
Josh. Allen is a great defensive
in great pass rusher.
Then you put a and Hutchinson in
there. They're gonna have
that first overall pick. That's
going to be two book in pass.
Rushers will see what they're
able to do. Let's get to your
third one, which is Mike Tom.
Hey, Jack, get this done Jack.
Get go ahead. You want to weigh
in on the Jags? Don't you go?
No, I was I was going.
Say I think you are spot on. I
don't think like everyone
thinks that the Jag job is just
a terrible job. I don't think
it's a terrible job. You talked
about like we saw Trevor
Lawrence man, and like this kid
looks really good at times, you
know, and if you bring in a are
being at me, you might bring
in a buyer left, which or Jim
Caldwell's. One of those guys
that really get this kid Focus.
Get this locker room built
together and not have so much
separate, so much, so many
separate entities. You get a
good coach in there that can
work with this kid, like a Jim
Caldwell, like Jim.
Call will too because I like his
demeanor. He's calm. He's
patient. Kind of reminds me of
Coach Dungy and I think
the Jacksonville Jaguars, but I
think you're spot on with that
assessment.
They could turn into something.
I'd be, I'd be fun to watch
down there. Let's get your third
takeaway, which is Mike
Tomlin.
Mike, Tom, when he took over as
a 35 year old head coach and
really, he's been a Trailblazer
for a whole bunch of these
young head coaches that have now
gotten opportunities. We
forget about that. When he first
took over 35, it was
like,
yeah, that seems awful young.
That's too young for.
Time head coach in the
Pittsburgh Steelers,
not one losing season for 15
years and the Pittsburgh
Steelers with old man. Big Ben
right back in the playoffs. How
in the hell he pull this off,
man? Let me tell you some, he is
a, heck of a coach and just
his support of Big Bend. When a
lot of people didn't support
Big Bend. I mean, he was very,
very supportive of Big Bend. He
was like, well, this is our
quarterback. This is what we're
going to do and think about
that. Offensive line. I've been
covering
and plan against the Steelers
for years
and this is probably one of the
top two or three worse.
It's offensive lines I've ever
seen him had
and they go in there. They draft
a young
running back, nausea hair is he
gets it over 1,000 yards
and but it's still a terrible
offense line. And you get Big
Ben. He can't move. He's stiff.
You got receivers dropping
passes
to me. I don't know how they end
up with a decent record
enough to get into the playoffs.
I think he did
a wonderful job, but it's to
support a Big Bend, is
the motivation, he and stealing
his players to keep playing
despite
all the different circumstances
that laser focus. Focus and him.
Mike Tomlin not carrying
around not caring about what
other people think, or what
they're doing or just really
focusing on his team and not
worrying about everybody else.
Great job by Mike Tomlin.
And speaking of not caring about
what other people are
doing, right? So this this was
the team that had to have been
the most nervous about a
potential tie as this Chargers.
Raiders game came down the home
stretch.
So here was coach Tomlin
on what he might have been doing
as all the drama, one of
the games. Really my opinion,
the game of the year was
unfolding with their playoff.
Chances. Hang in the balance.
Here's what he was up to.
I missed the end of it. I dozed
off.
I knew I had to work day waiting
on me. Or I assumed
that I had a work day
waiting on me.
I think, at one point, Oakland
was up by 15 and that number
made you somewhat comfortable.
I'm probably better off, not
having watched it.
So, it's probably not as
exciting of a description as
you would have hoped.
Well, you know, I'm looking
toward the future. And
the thing that I look at now is
they don't have to pay
a quarterback. 2530 million
bucks.
They need to get back to
focusing on that offensive
line. And that's the thing that
the Pittsburgh Steelers were
always known for like when I
knew him when I was playing
against him for years the
Pittsburgh Steelers, you always
had to bring your hard hat
because you know how physical
they're going to do what they're
going
to be. They're going to run the
football down your throat.
They're going to be physical.
They got during Monty Dawson,
Allen Santa. Could those guys
hot few you?
Hall of Fame, offensive linemen.
They got to get back
to being able to control and
dominate the line of scrimmage.
That's when they're at their
very best.
And now the second part of that
too, is also being able to go
out and sign Minka Fitzpatrick,
he's a free agent that you need
to sign him to a long-term
contract.
He's one of the best safeties in
the National Football
League, he's a do-it-all guy,
you could put them in slot, you
can put them down in a box, you
can keep them deep. He's going
to be a guy that's going to you
know, demand it
anywhere from 15 to 20 million
bucks a year. They have
To sign him. I think that would
be a smart thing to do.
Yeah, they just got real gritty
down the stretch, like this,
just became Pittsburgh Steeler
football. And they had some
hard games down the stretch of
the season. They got a little
lucky that Lamar Jackson was not
in the lineup so that they
could go play the
Ravens without and that's a
different kind of a ballgame,
but they went through their last
four to sneak into this
playoff. So, they earned this
thing down the stretch. And how
about mr. Watt? Mr. TJ W who
goes and gets the sack record,
steals it away
from Strahan. This, this is an
interesting one though, riding.
I'm curious your take on this
because With this 18-week
season 17 games.
The NFL record book is going to
be washed
and a lot of ways, right? You're
gonna see these
receiving records break,
quarterback records Sac records
break. How do you feel about
that as a guy who played in
a 16-game season for your the
entirety of your career?
I think they should have records
for 16 games and they
should have records for 17.
Yeah, I just, I just think
that,
but it's all part of it may, you
know, when you put up
records, they're going to be
broken. And, you know, a lot of
those guys they want their
records. That was some of those
guys say, you know, I don't
mind. My record being broken.
It's all part of it.
So I don't really have any,
like, you know, passionate
thoughts about it. I mean, it is
what it is at this point.
They all comes back to the
almighty dollar. That's what it
is. Anytime decisions are made,
you had actually week to
the season Almighty dollar. Get
to make a few extra bucks, but
football and the NFL's to me was
one of the last remaining
leagues
where your the record books
still matter, right? And I'm
baseball. You got the steroids
down if you got all that. So it
gets washed away. Football was
one of the final remaining ones
where you could go chase down
some of those old records
and it's still meant something.
I never liked the 18 week season
and this is a huge
reason why I'm happy for a
while. I'm happy for Guy like
Max Crosby with the Raiders.
You, it's 100 pressures, but
it's a whole nother thing, man,
when you got, you got an extra
week
to do it.
Hey Jack, but you got a man. You
got to come on man. Like we
got a chance to watch 17 weeks,
18 weeks of football. I mean,
how much fun did we have? How
much fun and they end up cap it
off with the last game of the
season
with the Raiders and the
Chargers may? Come on man. It
was just a blast. We it was just
unbelievable. My had
a blast this year.
It was it was there's the
perfect one to go out. Alright?
The last or the fourth of you
take aways the 49ers in
the Rams. It seems like the
49ers man. I don't know what it
is
about Shanahan. And
a guy who used to work
underneath of him and McVeigh.
He just seems to have his
number. He knows what it is and
he just keeps beating him. He
got him again and a game. Where
the Rams Head. Let how did he go
do this one rod.
They're not physical,
like
the Rams get beat by teams that
are physical. When you're
physical. You can run a
football, you come downhill,
you hit them in the mouth, like
the Tennessee Titans Doug.
They, we saw them, do
they just, they can't respond.
And that's the problem,
you know, and I just don't, I
don't believe in Matthew
Stafford. Matthew Stafford is a
guy that can put up a lot of
points. He looks good. But at
the end of the day, when you
put pressure on him and who has
more pressure on them,
in these playoffs did Matthew
Stafford.
Trust me. He understands that to
he knows that he has more
pressure on him than anybody
because the Rams gave up
a fortune to get him. He's
getting paid a lot of money and
expectations are super high.
They've traded a bunch of draft
picks and first,
you know, first round picks.
Now, you have Matthew Stafford
to me. I'm waiting
to see exactly Kenny Elevate
them to the next level, but I'm
not a big believer in this Rams
team because I just don't think
they're physical enough.
Yeah, no, that's real. And that
could be an issue. It was nice
to see I uke, right? And I, you
get going for the 49er side of
things as well. They've always
needed. Another receiver me
Debo Samuels, amazing. You
finally get George kiddo
healthy, which has
been good and Juwan Jennings.
How about this kid, right? And
he kind of came out of nowhere
in this game, but he was
clutch. It was over time. Fourth
quarter, had
the game-tying one to send it
into ot
to Big catches in overtime,
which settled down into field
goal range to go win it. So it's
new weapons around Jimmy.
Guys, we haven't seen him work
with at that high of a level
yet, but it's starting to come
to be a reality. Now
that the 49ers are playing like
this. And I tell you what, man,
we always know what they're able
to do with that run game.
It's one of the best run schemes
in the entire NFL. If
they can give Garoppolo a couple
of guys that he's
comfortable
with. You may see the 49ers put
together a sneaky run here
because they always play tough
defense when it comes to
January football.
Yeah, but the thing, you know,
the narrative out there is
a nobody wants to play the San
Francisco 49ers. Why not? Why
not? I would love to play the
San Francisco 49ers. You want
to know why
not? Because of kid or not
because of Debo Samuel. And
he's all these weapons because
of Jimmy G. I want a plan
because I don't believe Jimmy G
at this point in time. He can
come through consistently, in
the clutch. He
has not been able to do it
and hey, I'm not a big believer.
So everyone talking
about a you don't want to play
the San Francisco 49ers. Yes,
I do.
No question about it. I want to
play them and I want to see
exactly what Jimmy Jimmy G can
do on a big stage and if he can
continue to elevate his game,
each round will see what
happens, but I definitely
wouldn't mind playing the San
Francisco 49ers. I'm not afraid
of them.
Will she is right, but it's
always an interesting thing.
When, you know that the
quarterback, the coach, and
the quarterback really the head
coach and Shanna had the GM,
don't fully believe in their
quarterback and Jimmy
Garoppolo. They're not trading
that kind of loot to move up to
go get Trail ants, which I'm not
sure that they hit on that
pick, but you're not moving.
That kind of loot if you
believe he's a Super
Bowl quarterback, right? So if
the people in a house that
watch them, practice and play,
and they've seen him play all
these games, but they're
watching them on a day-to-day
basis operate. If Don't believe
in him.
It's hard as an outsider to
believe in him, but I got to
say, I've been impressed. That
just the fact that Jimmy
Garoppolo has been able to put
together this kind of season
knowing that, because nobody
knows that, they don't believe
in him better than Jimmy G. I
mean, you can imagine
if Aaron Rodgers is going, you
know, four fingers on
the Scotch after they picked
Jordan. Love, you can imagine
what Jimmy Garoppolo had to be
in feel enough. You trade all
that to go, get your
replacement. Lance.
Yeah, you know what and we are
so we'll sit back and see
exactly what Jimmy Jimmy does
and the playoffs but at the end
of the day like great players,
special players, get it done in
the big moments
in the big, big moments in the
playoffs. And if he can't get
it done in this big moment, I
think the San Francisco 49ers
this year, definitely, or in the
future. We'll move on from
him.
We'll find out man. Let's get to
your final takeaway, which
is Tennessee, the Tennessee
Titans all year long. It's
a team even without Derrick
Henry have just been right in
the thick of this thing man. He
comes back at AFC is going
through Tennessee is going to be
a home-field advantage
throughout for variable in the
Titans.
No doubt and Ryan Tannehill. He
has to be thrilled that he's
getting two of his best weapons
back. You get Derrick Henry and
when you bring dead, when
Derrick Henry comes in, it's
not like he's got to run the
ball. 25 times, Deonte form has
done a great great job of really
holding down.
The RAM and allowed him time to
come back. So when he comes
back, you'll see him get
anywhere from say, 10 to 15
touches,
10 to 15 touches. He'll share
and split carries with de'aunte
Foreman. Now, they had this to
man Run game and if in really
think about AJ Brown coming
back, he's healthy, but this is
what you need. You need this big
guy coming in wearing down
the
defense. He's a, such an
intimidating Factor. Then you
get a kind of a change of pace
guy that has very similar power
when it comes to Diaw. Auntie
Foreman,
but this is going to come down
to Ryan Tannehill, being able
to run, use the play-action
pass, being at a hit guys,
down. The field on deep routes,
20 plus yards and we'll see if
Ryan Tannehill can do it. If he
plays with that level of
confidence. But when I look at
the Tennessee,
Titans always say this,
they are the most physical team
that I've seen this year
and Mike Vrabel,
I'll speak about my variable in
a minute after this. But Mike
Vrabel will definitely be the
key.
They are and I also think about
it. Derrick Henry has fresh
legs, right? You got to imagine
that. They brought him back
slowly and they thought about
the moment of when they wanted
him back on the field. So I
think he's going to be healthy.
think you're going to see
a Derrick Henry. That's healthy.
He's also going to be fresh.
I mean, like, we talked about
with these 17 weeks. I mean,
these teams are beat up manic
some of these teams. The
Cincinnati Bengals are perfect
example,
they needed a week off, like
they had to take a week off and
week 17. So if Derrick Henry has
fresh legs, and now they
have two running backs. I mean,
they go 5 wide on that
offensive.
A lot of people that are just
pushing guys around while wad
saffold Jones, Davis
Quisenberry, all of those guys
are really good players. So if
they have that with some fresh
leg, Derrick Henry, now depth at
the running back position,
like you're talking about
and Tennessee could really be
something. We've already seen
them beat the rant. We've seen
him beat, so many of these
teams were in the playoffs last
year. They've already beaten
them this year. So, you know
that confidence is right there
along with it.
No question. Do you think about
variable being an experienced
coach? That was a former player
than played and coached in
a hot? The biggest moments in
the National Football League. So
he
understands what it takes.
He will have his team,
fundamentally ready,
and he will have them
mentally. Ready. So when they,
when they come out there,
they've already experienced it
because variables going to,
he's done a great job of really
preparing them for the moment.
So when I, when I look at the
Tennessee Titans, I'd say,
this is going to be a really a
hard out and the two teams that
I really like, I still like,
Kansas. City and I still like
the Tennessee Titans. It's going
to be tough to beat
the Titans.
Yeah, it's like the thing you
use for the 49ers, which is why
you would want to play them. I
think the Titans are here that
really applies to, I wouldn't
want to play the Tennessee
Titans especially having to go
to there.